HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
SEAN HANNITY IS NEXT.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, TUCKER.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THIS BREAKING NEWS
DEBATE EDITION.
THERE ARE NO MODERATES THAT ARE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN THE
SOCIALIST PARTY.
YOU ARE EITHER MORE RADICAL OR
LESS RADICAL.
THE NARRATIVE FROM FAKE NEWS,
CNN ABOUT A POLITICALLY DIVERSE
SET OF CANDIDATES.
THAT'S JUST THE NEWEST LIE.
THEY ALL SUPPORT SOME VERSION OF
THIS INSANE NEW GREEN DEAL.
THEY ALL SUPPORT RAISING YOUR
TAXES, AND THEY ALL SUPPORT
GOVERNMENT RUN UNIVERSAL
HEALTH CARE.
GUESS WHAT, THEY WANT FREE
HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THEY ALL WANT TO BUY INTO THE
LIE.
THIS IS ON HUMAN GROWTH HORMONES
AND STEROIDS.
IT'S APPLIED TO EVERY ASPECT OF
OUR ECONOMY.
IF WE HAVE NO OIL OR GAS, IT
WILL DESTROY THIS ECONOMY IN
WEEKS OR MONTHS.
THE IMPACT WILL BE SEEN
IMMEDIATELY.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THE VERY WORST
MOMENTS.
2020 WILL BE THE BIGGEST CHOICE
ELECTION IN OUR LIFETIME.
THIS IS A TIPPING POINT FOR THE
COUNTRY.
ANYONE THAT DOESN'T TELL YOU
THAT IS NOT TELLING YOU THE
TRUTH.
IT'S THAT DIRE.
WE WILL EITHER CONTINUE DOWN THE
PATH OF FREEDOM, CONSTITUTIONAL
GOVERNMENT, PROSPERITY,
CAPITALISM WITH GOVERNMENT
TRUMP, OR WE WILL PLUNGE INTO
THE DEPTHS OF SOVIET.
POVERTY WILL IMMEDIATELY FOLLOW
THEREAFTER.
WE HAVE SOME MAJOR BREAKING NEWS
SURROUNDING MR. SUPER PATRIOT
HIMSELF.
JIM KONY.
OUR FRIENDS HAVE JUST OBTAINED
SOME VERY COMPELLING DOCUMENTS.
HE PROBABLY DOESN'T WANT YOU TO
SEE THEM OR KNOW ABOUT.
AS IT TURNS OUT, IN JUNE 2017, 1
MONTH AFTER COMEY WAS FIRED,
AGENTS SHOWED UP AT HIS DOOR.
WHY DIDN'T WE FIND THIS OUT
SOONER?
THEY WERE THERE TO RETRIEVE HIS
PACIFIED DOCUMENTS WHICH HE WAS
STORING IN HIS HOME.
HE WAS GRILLED ABOUT THE
DOCUMENTS IN AN INTERVIEW.
BY THE WAY, THAT WOULD BE CALLED
AN INTERROGATION FOR THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
KEEP IN MIND, THESE ARE THE VERY
SAME MEMOS ABOUT CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL              PRESIE
PRESIDENTIAL              PRESIT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
MR. SUPER PATRIOT, COMEY NEVER
SHOULD HAVE HAD THOSE DOCUMENTS
AT HIS HOUSE.
OH, YEAH, LEAKING CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL IS A CRIME.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS HIS
BIGGEST CRIME, IN MY HUMBLE
OPINION.
I'VE TOLD SUPER PATRIOT JIM
COMEY, I'LL SAY IT AGAIN.
JIM, YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO
REMAIN SILENT.
MY ADVICE NOW MORE THAN EVER,
YOU NEED TO SHUT UP.
TAKE MY ADVICE.
THIS IS A BIG DISCOVERY.
I'LL BE HONEST.
AS FAR AS THE SINS OF JIM COMEY
AND THINGS THAT I THINK ARE
IMPORTANT, THE LEGALITY ISSUES
OF IT, THIS IS THE LOW-HANGING
FRUIT.
THIS IS THE LEAST IMPORTANT.
WHAT HE DID ON PFIZER AND
ELSEWHERE WILL BE FAR MORE
IMPORTANT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
OVER TIME.
>> WELL, IT'S PART OF.
COMEY TOOK THE FBI FILES THAT HE
HAD ON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
KEPT THEM AT HIS HOME, WHICH IS
ILLEGAL.
HE USED THEM FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES PAIRED HE LEAKED THEM
TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES" ."
COINCIDENTALLY, HIS FRIEND
ROBERT MUELLER, DISAPPOINTED.
LOOK, NO LEAK OF THE MEMOS.
NO SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THIS IS A PRETTY BIG DEAL.
NOW, WE KNOW FOR THE FIRST TIME
THAT THE FBI WAS INVESTIGATING
HIS CREATION AND HANDLING OF
THESE MEMOS.
THEY SHOW UP AT HIS HOUSE, THEY
ARE INTERVIEWING HIM, AND HE
STILL HAS THESE MEMOS.
COME ON GUYS.
THIS IS A VIOLATION OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RIGHTS.
HE KEEPS THEM THERE AT HIS
HOUSE.
HE DOESN'T TELL THEM THAT HE IS
LEAKING THEM.
HE ADMITS TO AT THE NEXT DAY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE PRESIDENT IS
THE VICTIM HERE.
HE IS THE VICTIM OF SEVERAL
CRIMES, IN MY VIEW, COMMITTED BY
COMEY, IN TERMS OF TAKING FBI
FILES AND LEAKING THEM.
>> Tucker: TOM, WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WATCH JUDICIAL